talking I think what we need to be doing
globally is talking to one another I
think there needs to be a great deal
more global understanding I think that
is the only way in which we can get to a
place where we understand that we are
not going to be able to solve some of
these global problems alone individually
as separate countries we're going to
have to find ways of cooperating
collaborating so that we can see that
we're all in this mess together so I
think that what we are not doing enough
of is finding the common ground that
will bring us together I I think the
most important thing that each one of us
can do individually is to educate
ourselves about what the issues are
stretch ourselves so that we like the
students at Princeton encounter the
other so that we begin a process of
understanding why people who live in
Egypt or in Saudi Arabia or in a rock
fundamentally think differently than we
do and understanding the history of that
and why that is true so I think we have
an obligation to understand why there is
so much difference in the world today
and then get to the point of
understanding that despite those
differences we're not going to change
those differences how we are going to
come together and unite to solve some of
the horrible problems we face
you